chest is deep
chest is infinite chest is a mirror of
yourself
chest is a metaphor for life and chess
is
a search for the truth wrestling brings
determination confidence toughness
heart love chess is intellectual
wrestling
it's all about making great decisions on
every single move pick someone's mind
before a match and having a mental edge
already
can gain you so much confidence before
you even step out on the mat
preparation and chess is a big thing you
form a profile of your opponents about
their preferences their weaknesses their
strengths and
definitely make your game plan i'm
prepared before i even go to the
tournament
i think about how i'm just gonna step
out and put on a show for the people
there's a famous saying about
chess that you only need to see one good
move ahead once you learn
how cutthroat chess can be you are
one-on-one
players are attacking each other one
false move and you're dead
it's do or die if this guy wins i'm the
dead man for the week
fighting spirit and just refusing to
give up are the skills that are going to
always help you succeed in chess me
creating my own legacy with the name
gable
has a different sake to it grandbastar
is the highest title you can get in
chess
it's the badasses of the game you sit at
the top
and everybody else tries to come and
knock this off
it is my time to win
[Music]